- You know black don't crack, right?
- No it don't, look at this.
Look at this, look at this.
- What's up y'all?
I'm Daysha.
- And I'm Pedro.
- We're here at the 2016
BET Awards and we're
going to play the black don't crack quiz.
- Man, let's do it.
Come on, I'm ready.
- Let's see what's up.
- [Voiceover] Which Pharrell
Williams is younger?
- Oh, this is hard.
- They look the same.
- That's Pharrell in the future and
that's Pharrell in the past.
Ain't none of them from the present.
- I know that's the younger one because
he got a fur on.
- Ha! Yes!
- I can look at the skin.
- That's because he washing
his face with cold water.
I read a lot about Pharrell.
- [Voiceover] Which
Gabrielle Union is younger?
- I don't want to get in trouble
picking the wrong one, bro.
- Geez.
- They look the same!
- Come on, that's my baby right there.
- Younger.
(buzzer)
- Damn.
Okay.
- Yeah, I said that one.
- I got that wrong.
- Oh my gosh, she's just beautiful.
- See my eyes, didn't see
which one I was looking at.
It was the wrong one.
- [Voiceover] Which
Angela Bassett is younger?
- Oh, that's hard.
- This is not easy.
- That one.
- Nah.
- No, no.
- That one.
(dings)
(cheers)
- Yes!
- I know because she has that haircut now.
- Either falling out or they
got to go with their short doo.
I know.
- They both look beautiful.
I love me some Angela.
- I want to marry Angela Bassett.
- Thank you for playing.
- No problem.
Two out of three.
- But you're right,
black don't crack, baby.
We just glistening in the sun.
Look like we been frying chicken.
- I love being black.
I'm black and I'm proud.
Both of them.
Look at me, I'm melanin.
(creaking)